hey what's going on guys it's jake and
today i have something pretty different
for you so
i was just kind of roaming around the
world you know i'm trying to figure out
everything in this game so that i can
bring you guys as much information about
elden ring as i possibly can i think i
have about 120 hours in the game at this
point uh which is like right in the
middle of the pack i would say probably
a little bit more than the usual casual
player
and i was i was just exploring
stormville castle and i came across this
area over here to the right that i'm not
sure is so secret like i'm sure tons of
people have found this area over here
you drop down you take a little bit of
damage and
there's this pretty elusive
underground area over here and this
isn't going to be the topic of this
video again i'm sure most people have
seen this at least i haven't uh until i
started exploring around in my new game
plus three we've got some uh
some ruined statues down here it's kind
of like a forgotten part
of the castle it seems like and i'll
show you guys what i mean in a minute
got some rats down here to deal with no
big deal
got a big rat over here as well
bleed is op
and
again there's just like ruins around
like ruined buildings ruin statues ruin
parts of the castle down here like
something happened like something
exploded through this area and then i
came across this
now when you drop down here i'm not sure
if it's gonna spawn again i really hope
it doesn't because i hate fighting these
things uh i forget what it's called it's
one of those giant worm things that
looks like it's not gonna respawn i'll
i'll show you a little bit of a clip of
it but after you beat these things and
you start looking around you're like
what what is this down here like what
what am i looking at it's just like
these kind of coffin
boat type things with you know lit you
know lanterns everywhere
and then
you know like like this was covered like
with a tarp this whole area right here
and i start making my way this way
and there's this guy
now
i don't know what this is
it's kind of disturbing to look at
because that's very clearly a nose
and these are very clearly eyes and when
i hit it it bleeds now it's not the
katana i even tested it i can test it
with another weapon if you want to
um
it bleeds
no matter what i hit it with it bleeds
so
either it's clearly alive
somewhere in there i don't know but off
of this guy right here you receive an
item it's a talisman called the prince
of death's
hustle
hustle i don't know how to say that
but the description says a fetid pustel
taken from facial flesh and it raises
your vitality vitality governs
resistance of the effects of death it is
said that this pustule came from the
visage of the prince of death he who
used to be called
godwin as first dead of the demigods it
said he's buried deep under the capital
at the erd trees roots
and i started to remember when i was
doing fia's questline i feel like i
really recognized this this creepy
face that's sprouting what looks like
squid tentacle
root things coming out underneath it how
did it get down here why was it being
clearly covered up
there's a ladder here now this ladder is
extremely
extremely long
like it goes way the hell up so they
clearly knew that this was down here
whether it fell down here or a battle
happened that it just created this
massive crater in the ground what
happened here what why are they trying
to cover this up is all i think of we're
starting to get i mean this ladder just
never stops it just keeps going
something clearly
fell down here it kind of reminded me of
radon's uh shooting star coming out of
the ground totally forgotten area like
you can't get up here unless you went
the direction that i did like the path
that i did so
i'm just wondering what that is and then
i remembered
i've been to the ur tree roots before i
i know where that is so if you go
underground and you will eventually get
here you will get to the deep root
depths and you'll find the prince of
death's throne and when you get here
something looks very familiar
look right over here
that right
there that looks pretty familiar to me
you can take a closer look with the
telescope here that looks exactly like
what we saw down below except it
actually has
whether he's alive or not i don't know
what this is but he's definitely got eye
sockets or he's got eyeballs in the eye
sockets and they look dead he's got the
same
little like pimple
at the top he's got the same nose the
same like
flakes coming off the back
so apparently i mean this is
this is god one
that's who this is the this is godwin
and he's connected to this i mean
through fia's questline obviously
is her body still here yep her body's
still here i didn't kill her but dee did
the the guy named d in the round table
castle he kills her and she said that
she was going to lie with godwin and if
you look here i mean this looks like a
fish
like fish scales or maybe even a snake
of some kind being wrapped up again in
some sort of cloth i mean very clearly
we have a connection to these two faces
on the ground that we've seen i'm very
curious of what you all think this means
or who this is and and how this happened
how did he get down here
did he unshell his face like is he a
snake where he can
you know
take himself out of his skin and shed
his skin and go somewhere else like who
knows man in these caves what is that
over there
what is that
that looks like a ring
is that a hand
yep
wait a minute
right there you it's it's kind of hard
because i can't get the lighting on it
very well but
that's clearly an arm coming out
and that's some kind of ring with a that
looks like maybe a tiny thumb and some
fingers this is very strange i i didn't
really notice this in my first two
playthroughs but now that i'm really
exploring everything in this game
there's some connection between here and
whatever was underneath stormdale castle
obviously so again i'm really curious
what you guys think of this let me know
down in the comments and let's let's try
and figure it out together peace and
love everybody have a great day